it will haunt you every night whatever
it is no one should have to encounter
that kind of evil except you girls I
think you can handle it oh oh good
thanks we have a gift we see what no one
else is willing to see we do things
others can't do those buses
if there's a paranormal problem we are
the ones to answer the call hello what
do we think of these ghostbusters are
they to be taken seriously okay so I
don't know if it was a race thing or a
lady thing but I'm mad as hell there's a
bigger picture at hand here someone is
creating a device that amplifies
paranormal activity we're gonna need a
bigger boat hey guys check it out I was
born to be a Ghostbuster all right
oh man that's so not good
something big is gonna happen the word
we're looking for is the populace yeah
the government's trying to claim the
event isn't supernatural we don't want a
panic
you don't want miss area no I'm tired
no no just gonna go ahead and take off
how about that I going to take off don't
piss off the ghost
really